bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 17 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
mais aussi des journalistes de la
rédaction
ou comment se fit avec les titres de
cette édition la ville de coignières
dispose maintenant d'un nouveau pôle
santé pluridisciplinaire il regroupe 12
praticiens médicaux et paramédicaux sur
une superficie de 550 m² invités pour en
parler le docteur gilles fleury co
responsable du site
paris-nice 2016 s'est dévoilée ce jeudi
avec l'annoncé du parcours l'une des
premières grandes courses à étapes de la
saison propose une nouvelle fois aux
coureurs de s'élancer des yvelines et
nous est à présent dans une semaine nous
verrons comment se préparent les
traiteurs pour répondre à la demande
nous rencontrerons aussi les amateurs de
décorations et d'illuminations et puis
noël c'est avant tout un moment de
solidarité et les associations se
mobilisent une annonce impopulaires mais
nécessaires pierre bédier président du
conseil départemental a déclaré cette
semaine que les yvelinois devrait
s'attendre à une forte hausse d'impôts
selon nos confrères du parisien
l'élu a une nouvelle fois dénoncé la
baisse des dotations de l'état toujours
selon lui la dotation globale de
fonctionnement va purement et simplement
disparaître de 100 euros par habitant
elle va passer à 10 euros le montant de
la hausse n'est pas encore connue
cette décision avait déjà été évoquée
lors du mandat en cours de pierre bédier
l'annoncé officielle devrait avoir lieu
ce vendredi lors de la réunion des élus
du conseil départemental qui débattront
des orientations budgétaires de 2016 et
nous accueillons ce soir en plateau le
docteur roger fleury bonsoir et merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
alors ton nous parler du nouveau pôle
santé de la ville de coignières il a
ouvert au mois de novembre c'est une
bonne date car la période des fêtes est
en général chargé cette année pour les
médecins c'est vrai c'est une période
chargée épidémique bien sûr mais pour
les médecins généralistes maintenant
s'est chargé toute l'année puisque nous
sommes de moins en moins nombreux et
par conséquent nous héritons des défunts
de la patientèle de nos confrères parti
en retraite en général et son successeur
la plupart du temps m² voilà c'est comme
une surface assez grand lille i à 12
praticiens c'était une nécessité d'avoir
ce nouveau pôle de son témoignage
c'était une nécessité pour la première
raison qui a que nous étions déjà à
coignières dans un vieux bâtiment ce
bâtiment n'était plus du tout aux normes
pour pouvoir accueillir les personnes
handicapées la date butoir théoriquement
c'était 2015 est donc cet ancien
bâtiment n'était pas du tout adaptable
donc on avait deux alternatives soit
quitter coignières soit trouvée à une
possibilité à quoi guerre et après de
longs débats avec la municipalité nous
avons pu trouver ce deal qui est
excellent excellente d'abord pour les
connais rien qui ne perdent pas leur
médecin et puis bien entendu pour les
praticiens qui ont un bâtiment désormais
parfaitement adapté à la situation qui
est très beau et qui nous satisfait
pleinement
mais les grands gagnants ça reste bien
entendu les poignées rien alors
maintenant donc ce pôle santé est aux
normes pour les personnes handicapées
justement avant nous avions des
escaliers nous n'avions pas de
possibilité de créer un ascenseur des
couloirs étroits et ses normes pour
l'accueil des handicapés sont
extrêmement strictes et exigeante et
donc savez tout à fait impossible donc
maintenant nous sommes aux normes une
somme très content de l'être et les quoi
n'y a rien de sûr aussi
alors se pose sans cesse ça fait depuis
2000 2008 que vous l'attendiez oui c'est
ça depuis 2008 on a commencé à discuter
avec la municipalité depuis 2008
ça a été une longue négociation ça a été
parfois difficile ce qui conduirait là
donc on avait deux existent de
difficultés qui sont là le bâti qui
n'était pas adapté donc à les créer à
nouveau bâti financièrement c'est bien
entendu hors dé portée des petites
structures donc la municipalité a bien
compris cette nécessité là
il a coûté un million huit cent mille
euros dont le bâtiment c'est un
investissement qui comme conséquent la
leur ai fait un gros effort dessus oui
les coins yayi en fait un gros effort
c'est évident alors c'est un bâtiment
qui comprend le centre médical
proprement dit et puis la pmi qui
malheureusement depuis a fermé et dont
on espère qu'elle va trouver une autre
fonction m'est donc effectivement parmi
les les
doulaye actuellement tous les bureaux ne
sont pas occupés un espoir très vif de
faire entrer de nouveaux praticiens
malgré les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer à cela alors cette
mutualisation des praticiens ainsi on
peut le dire vrai c'est comme une bonne
chose car c'est quand même très
compliqué même en région parisienne
voient d'avoir des rendez-vous
facilement avec les différents médecins
c'est tout à fait difficile
effectivement les autres fois il n'était
pas concevable de d'attendre plus de vue
quelques heures pour pouvoir rencontrer
un généraliste
aujourd'hui on donne des rendez-vous à
24 à 48 heures des fois plus aimé ça
tient effectivement au fait qu' on a des
plannings qui sont pas extensibles même
contre eux soit tard on est de moins en
moins nombreux et on a beaucoup de mal à
recruter des remplaçants des successeurs
des associés du fait de d'une part du
numerus clausus qui réduit le nombre de
praticiens qui sortent des universités
d'autre part parce que ces praticiens
préfèrent en général rester à l'hôpital
et délaissent souvent la médecine
générale qui est considéré comme une
exercice exigeant difficile
c'est plein d'excès d'être médecin
généraliste en cabine et à l'hôpital des
médecins généralistes à l'hôpital il y
en a pas assez sont des gérants là ce
sont des spécialistes
donc voilà c'est mieux d'être à
l'hôpital en termes c'est plus
confortable pour tout un tas de raisons
bien entendu
les hospitaliers ont un statut de
salarié avec tout ce qui se rattache à
cela
les libéraux doivent fonctionner tout
seul doivent être un peu
homme-orchestre de il faut savoir et
bien entendu exercer son métier mais il
faut aussi avoir piloté une structure
comme celle ci est on est en contact
direct avec tout un tas d'instance qui
sont la sécurité sociale les instances
professionnelles l'ordre on a des
exigences fiscales comptable techniques
par exemple salle d'aubière la loi
handicap
donc tout ça ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué et c'est une des raisons qui
est sans parler des contraintes horaires
des personnes à peu près ça c'est
variable selon les saisons mais oui
c'est l'ordre de grandeur oui du coup
alors il y a des médecins généralistes
dans ce nouveau centre des médecins
généralistes un gynécologue des
infirmières une kiné des podologues nous
avions autrefois dentiste quine à 20 kg
est parti sans successeur nous voudrions
absolument qu'un dentiste pire venir il
ya une grosse demande sur la commune et
dans la périphérie
il ya un local qui est superbe pour cela
donc on appelle un candidat d'entraidé
administrative notamment bien entendu
pas que mes mais oui notamment un
dentiste
alors qui sont les personnes les
patients accueillis donc dans ce centre
de coignières c'est juste les habitants
de quoi niort ça c'est randy donner plus
que les habitants de konya bien sûr ce
sont les familles de coignières 4500
habitants ça occupe déjà bien
naturellement mais de plus en plus des
patients des communes avoisinantes
qu'en dire je le mesnil saint denis
maurepas saremi l'honorer la verrière et
cdd patients aussi qu'ils ont quitté la
commune pour habiter dans des communes
limitrophes mais qui me sont restés
fidèles par exemple comment vous
expliquer qu'il ya très peu de pôle
santé comme celui ci qui se forme qui
sont présents les villes c'est compliqué
pour les médecins pour les mairies de
gérer ce genre de structure c'est
qu'enfin l'expérience montre que c'est
oui c'est assez compliqué le dossier des
charges pour recréer ce genre de
structure est assez lourd et les les
municipalités lorsque j'entends de la
part de nos collègues ont souvent un
petit peu de mal à comprendre la vraie
réalité des difficultés des praticiens
libéraux il faut bien reconnaître que
avec un gros travail avec beaucoup de
temps on annule finalement beaucoup de
chance à coignières de d'être entendu
est ce que justement la fermeture vous
équiper m'y étais juste à coller où il
ya pas mal de pays amis tu fermes ça
vous impact aussi ça vous fait plus
justement ça remonte à sera pas
seulement bien suivre oui là la pmi donc
affirmer à coignières les patients sont
obligés de se déplacer à willencourt
on m'a cité plusieurs situations où les
palais on leur donnait des rendez vous
très lointain il ya un temps de
déplacement il ya beaucoup de passes de
familles qui n'ont pas de voiture
les bus sont pas toujours commode donc
effectivement on hérite de ses nouveaux
patients de plus surcroît le poids santé
sera ouvert pendant les vacances les
fêtes de fin d'année je suis alors on
nous on a la chance d'être par exemple
de médecins généralistes dont constat
alternent pour les vacances pour les
pour les week-ends enfin il ya toujours
quelqu'un de présent on c'est une chose
à laquelle on est extrêmement attentif
mais effectivement c'est pas partout
comme ça et qu'on me dire je crois qu'il
ya un médecin tout seul par exemple
quantique antilles et qu'il ne peut pas
trouver de remplaçants parce que c'est
souvent le cas ben oui quand il part il
confie à aux médecins autour sans
forcément donner des directives très
précises à ses patients et voilà vous
attendez encore quelques médecins
l'appel est lancé donc c'est pour un
anti est un artiste un ophtalmo il ya
une grosse demande un dermato par
exemple oui bien sûr eh bien merci à
vous courrez docteur floride est devenu
en plateau et avoir répondu à nos
questions sur l'évolution parlons noël à
présent pendant les fêtes de fin d'année
les boutiques ne sont pas les seuls à
remplir leur carnet de commandes pour
les traiteurs c'est aussi une période où
l'activité s'intensifie notamment en ce
qui concerne les demandes des
particuliers williams elle s'est rendue
chez lars traiteur à magny les hameaux
pour en savoir un peu plus sur leur
organisation
ne différent pas sa cote différentes
équipes
tous aux fourneaux que ce soit au froid
ou chaud pendant la période des fêtes
les traiteurs s'active en cuisine pour
l'instant chez ce traiteur de magny les
hameaux l'activité reste stable mais
leur carnet de commandes s'étoffe pour
les journées du 24 et du 31 décembre
et pour l'occasion en plus de la carte
habituelle un menu spécial noël a été
mis en place
les incontournables comme d'habitude le
chapon indémodable sur le gibier on est
sur un pavé de serre fait dans le dos un
grand classique
ensuite sur le poisson nous avons fait
une papillote mx 1 et 3 passes ont
encore incorporé élaboré avec une sauce
aux sons de base de champignons tuchan
petite à réchauffer le plaisir à
la dégustation
le but n'est pas forcément de marché
extrêmement sur le produit mais plus de
satisfaire notre clientèle
on sait que ça un moment familial il
faut qu'on soit à la portée nos clients
l'entreprise enregistre déjà 60
commandes aux particuliers pour le soir
de noël mais en prévoit environ 150
d'ici le 24 décembre
malgré un marché de plus en plus
concurrencé par les industriels de la
grande distribution
aujourd'hui voilà on est sûr on va dire
une stagnation du nombre moyen de
commandes depuis trois années sur la
carte des fêtes
cependant on
mais mais assez satisfait du fait de
pouvoir résister par rapport à ses
autres acteurs du marché
l'entreprise qui table aussi sur deux
grands axes de clientèle comme les
plateaux repas et l'événementiel a vu
l'activité de ce dernier baissé au vu
des événements du mois de novembre
certains particuliers fidèles et
habitués resteront toujours les
meilleurs ambassadeurs de l'entreprise
auprès de ses clients occasionnels de
cette période de l'année
et qui dit noël dit forcément
illuminations de noël à coignières un
concours est même organisée depuis une
quinzaine d'années les particulière
redoublent d'imagination pour décorer la
façade de leur maison et offrir aux
passants un petit moment de
contemplation camille et lombaires est
allé à la rencontre de ces passionnés
serge peaufine encore les détails même
sous le mauvais temps père noël et
bonhommes de neige conf la blonde
investi le devant de sa maison comme
chaque année depuis maintenant 12 ans il
illumine le quartier certains font même
le déplacement pour admirer ces
décorations
il ya beaucoup de passants qui me qui
viennent oui des petits enfants le soir
beaucoup aussi qu'ils pensent oui des
fois il ya même la une file de voitures
ils n'y font la queue une trentaine de
guirlandes de semaine d'installation et
des centaines de lumières
serge participent au concours
d'illuminations organisée par la mairie
de coignières sa collection
il a accumulé au fil des années tous les
ans on change un peu faux enfin change
on change de couleur surtout aussi une
fois ces bleus blancs là cette année on
a fait multicolores et puis on a remis
dégonflant plus que les autres années on
n'avait pas me dégonfler et dans sa rue
il n'est pas le seul
marc lui a misé sur les père noël tout
en musique
un rendez vous annuel auquel marc le
rohellec participe depuis une dizaine
d'années mais l'une des autres stars du
quartier c'est la maison d'isabelle
trois fois gagnante du concours elle
mise tout sur le pôle nord la région du
père noël
ça commence c'est cette histoire avec
des ours c'est que quelqu'un m'a offert
trois petits ours et puis je me suis dit
je dis qu'est ce que je vais en faire
beh dit tiens je vais pourquoi pas en
faire un petit coin pour l'honneur
moi j'appelle ça le bonheur et puis de
l'autre côté je me dis tiens plein de
peyreleau had bah je vais faire la
maison du père noël dans son allée les
personnages se comptent par dizaines
les ampoules par milliers alors il faut
quand même un peu d'organisation
bah moi je l'état par en dessous
l'écart est derrière il y en a encore
pour la déco des guirlandes des
sculptures et même une crèche un travail
important qui vaut le coup selon
isabelle petit ou grand c'est un moyen
de tous nous apporter du rêve est de
faire durer un peu plus la magie de noël
et les fêtes de fin d'année sont souvent
synonymes d'événements festifs mais pour
certains elle renvoie au contraire à de
longs moments de solitude différentes
associations solidaires se mobilisent
dans les yvelines particulièrement dans
cette période pour permettre à tous de
rompre l'isolément et de passer de
belles fêtes de fin d'année de coutume à
noël une assiette libre était
généralement laissées en bout de table
pour le pauvre
aujourd'hui cet esprit de solidarité se
décline un peu différemment
à l'image de l'association les petits
frères des pauvres qui oeuvre contre
l'isolément des personnes âgées
l'association organise différentes
initiatives comme mercredi à villepreux
un noël intergénérationnel avec des
lycéens
c'est donc avant tout organiser
aussi bien les comptes que les danses et
chorégraphies ont été faites par des
élèves
les textes ont aussi fait part des
élèves tout a été organisé par les
élèves
on a fait ses activités pour pour réunir
les différentes générations tant les
enfants nous les personnes plus âgées
c'est et comme vous pouvez le voir ça se
passe très bien que quand on voit les
enfants qui sont tous joyeux les
personnes âgées si c'est vrai c'est très
émouvant quand même
distraire et puis passer un bon moment
en bonne compagnie le plaisir de voir
que notre jeunesse
elle est bien vivante noël symbole de
moments joyeux en famille mais pas pour
tous cette fête peut également renvoyer
à une période de détresse pour les
personnes souffrant de solitude
les bénévoles des associations comme sos
amitié se mobilise particulièrement en
ce moment
sos un petit bonjour oui man show je
vous écoute
nous sommes là le jour de noël nous
sommes là la veille de noël sommes là le
31 décembre et le 1er janvier
il apprécie les écoutants qui sont là et
c'est c'est souvent un grand merci de
leur part merci d'être là on est
peut-être les seules personnes qui vont
leur souhaiter une bonne année
le manque de moyens les difficultés
économiques sont d'autant plus lourdes
en cette période de fin d'année
c'est pourquoi le secours populaire
s'organise autour de différentes actions
comme la distribution attrape d'un colis
alimentaire spécial noël saumon bûche
ballotin de chocolat et même des jouets
pour les enfants
je redis festive selon l'organisme pour
que les gens aient un
de fait des fêtes de fin d'année à noël
comme comme les autres voilà tout
simplement
et donc on va aider plus de 2000
familles sur le département à bojan pour
avoir les fêtes de fin d'année qui soit
comme tout le monde de ne pas se sentir
mis à l'écart c'est une bonne initiative
pour les pauvres déjà parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup plus tard qu'ils ont pas les
moyens de payer pour le web des trucs de
nous offrir ça pour la fin de l'année
ses formes et à tous les bénévoles sont
toujours les bienvenues lors de ses
belles initiatives pour perpétuer
l'esprit solidaire de ces fêtes de fin
d'année et nous refermons cette page de
noël pour ouvrir celle du sport le
parcours de la course cycliste paris
nice a été dévoilé aujourd'hui à l'hôtel
du département de versailles les
yvelines accueilleront le prologue de la
compétition à conflans sainte honorine
et la petite commune de condé sur vègre
organisera le départ de la première
étape
les détails avec michael ni d'euros et
mary loisel c'est une tradition pour la
septième année consécutive la course
cycliste paris nice organisé du 6 au 13
mars s'élancera depuis les yvelines
la ville de conflans sainte honorine a
été choisi pour le prologue de cette
soixante quatorzième édition
elle succède à maurepas au programme une
difficulté le sentier des laveuses une
cote de 200 m une petite difficulté qui
assez courte qu'on aurait dû classé hors
catégorie du tour de france mais qui va
en arrêter plus d'un qui va provoquer d
d d écart à l'arrivée et ensuite un
parcours beaucoup plus plat pour aller
chercher la ligne d'arrivée donc un beau
décor d'ensemble je pense qu'on va avoir
d'excellentes images ça donne un peu le
ton de la semaine de paris fut
pourcentage raid cours mais réelle et
puis un parcours où il vraiment
séduisant qui est fait pour tous les
types de coureurs donc vivement
printemps une deuxième vie sera à
l'honneur sur ce paris-nice 2016 condé
sur vos grands 1159 habitants a été
sélectionnée pour accueillir la première
étape de la compétition
une première pour ce village situé près
de rambouillet ça va faire drôle de voir
les bus des équipes dans ce village
toute cette animation mais non mais
c'est ça le cyclisme aujourd'hui on se
déplace partout quoi le stade c'est le
stade il va partout où il va dans les
villes de 50 habitants s'ils voyaient en
irak et donc on est sûr vexé parfait
c'est parfait pour nous le tracé
programmés dans les deux villes
yvelinoise a séduit les coureurs
présents ce jeudi à l'hôtel du
département de versailles pour la
présentation officielle
il est complètement je serai encore pour
hors jeu
je pense que je serais venu sur ce
paris-nice
pourquoi pas je te reprendre le vélo
mais non non il me plaît énormément je
pense qu'on va avoir du beau spectacle
c'est surtout ça qui est important
une centaine de coureurs est attendu sur
paris-nice parmi les têtes d'affiché on
retrouvera les stars françaises romain
bardet tony gallopin l'australien richie
porte et l'espagnol alberto contador
vainqueur du tour de france et nous
recevons à présent sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif et ses invités
michael almy d'euros bon sauf lorraine
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur les
templiers d'elancourt le club de
football américain est actuellement en
pleine préparation pour la saison
prochaine et qu'il ne reprendra le
championnat qu'en février pour nous
parler de cette structure
les objectifs du club nous recevons sur
ce plateau georges agostino le président
du club et le directeur sportif dyke
painchaud bonsoir alors georges la ligne
arrière n'a pas été une grande saison
vous avez loupé les premiers matches on
va dire ça comme ça
est-ce que ça a été vraiment déterminant
dans la suite du championnat oui bien
sûr on a très mal débuté la saison à
domicile à domicile surtout bon sur veut
résumer vite fait on a perdu des matches
importants qui nous empêcher d'aller en
play-offs d'aller plus loin on a gagné
ce qu'il fallait pas perdre pour pas
descendre en deuxième division on s'est
maintenus ce n'est pas une grande saison
parce que l'objectif était légèrement
supérieur mais voilà il voit la saison
et il faudra gagner dès ce premier match
frédéric painchaud dès ce premier match
faudra gagner le 6 février
oui il faudrait contre ça sera contre
les gladiateurs de la cuve rien voilà
les premières exactement où il faudra
gagner puisque c'est on va dire l'équipe
qui monte de la division 2 donc qu'il ne
faut pas perdre contre eux puisque après
on se met dans des dans une situation
compliquée et en plus c'est à domicile
c'est à domicile c'est chez nous le
problème est l'objectif ça sera quoi
justement de faire un petit peu de votre
stade une forteresse imprenable cette
saison
cette saison ça va être de refaire du de
notre stade du complexe de l'europe une
forteresse un endroit compliqué un
endroit difficile à jouer
bref où les autres équipes n'aiment pas
venir rencontrer les templiers
george est ce que les temples y font
partie des favoris sur cette saison ou
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres équipes qui
si grave ou font peur on fait partie des
outsiders
d'ailleurs on va dire qu'il ya des clubs
beaucoup de grands clubs français qu'il
était déjà se sont énormément pour
renforcer nous on essaie de faire d'où
la venue et la présence de freddy points
chauds l'essai de votre deux directeurs
sa part ne vous dirais tout directeur
sportif on essaie de se renouveler
d'avoir des nouvelles idées ce qui a
marché à un moment donné ne marche plus
toutant objectif sur objectifs je
laisserais fred en parler on va essayer
de faire le mieux possible cette année
puisque c'est une année de transition on
avait viella vivier jeunes on à viviez
seniors on va vraiment essayer de faire
le maximum
personnellement si on arrive à la porte
du play-off aux play-offs je serais
personnellement content l'année dernière
la saison était très difficile la saison
d'avant par contre ça va fonctionner on
peut dire ça comme ça
finalement vous réussissez une saison
sur deux donc cette saison logiquement
doré tout terrasse et on va dire que la
saison dernière a été une conséquence
d'une saison hyper réussi à l'année
précédente et qui s'est terminée
malheureusement dans des conditions un
petit peu difficile pour nous voilà donc
donc c'est l'année qui a suivi a été
compliqué puisque beaucoup de joueurs
avaient un petit peu lâché lâché l
affaire ne s'était pas réimpliquer 100%
est donc cette année et ben on a fait un
peu table rase de tout ce qui s'est
passé et on l'a fait on a décidé de se
remettre au travail de changer beaucoup
de choses changer des têtes changent et
des coachs échanger des organisations et
la structure un petit peu la faire
évoluer
donc de nouveau coach donc des nouveaux
coaches à nouveau être coach emmanuel
charest a préféré quitter puisqu'il
décide est de de se tourner vers autre
chose vers d'autres objectifs donc
emmanuel nous a quittés il a été
remplacé au est coaching par
par le coach principal michael marion
qui était déjà coaché nous donc on garde
toujours un petit peu un peu de famille
un peu de personnes qui viennent de chez
nous et on a restructuré un petit peu
les autres coaches avec des nouvelles
têtes ce qui permet un peu aux joueurs
qui sont là depuis très longtemps de
changer de routine d'entraînement et il
ya des américains qui voudront genre
voilà alors pour l'instant il y en a 1
puisque le deuxième il est en attente
encore et que c'est une petite surprise
donc on le garde en garder sous la main
on en a un qui était on va dire en
quelque sorte en vacances en france et
qui ne savaient pas qu'on jouait au
football américain en france et qui est
venu un jour selon qu'on nous rencontrer
et nous a proposé ses services et quand
on s'est renseigné sur lui
on s'est aperçu que c'était est un très
très bon joueur un excellent joueur et
qui voit là il a décidé de signer chez
nous parce qu'il trouvait l'ambiance du
club très très sympa donc deux mois de
fin mois et demi on va dire du premier
match est ce qu'on peut dire que
l'équipe est prête
l'effectif est au complet l'effectif
n'est pas ou est ce que l'objectif peut
encore être modifié l'effectif peut être
modifié et déjà on est déjà à 80 90 % de
l'effectif mais il peut être encore être
modifié alors on part aussi avec une
autre un autre objectif c'est que cette
année d'une joueront pas avec un
américain en quarterbacks ça c'est la
petite différence des autres équipes
françaises c'est pour ça qu'on a
peut-être pas une ambition de titre ou
de podium mais on partira avec un
quarterback jeune quarterback français
qui était qui et en équipe de france et
qui jouent et avant chez notre ennemi
juré chez les flashs
voilà on a réussi à voler à l'un de
leurs joueurs
il a décidé il a cru dans notre projet
notre projet sportif qui est de remettre
au poste de quarterback un français pour
pourquoi pas le faire jouer en équipe de
france et pourquoi pas briller
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour la suite enfin pour le
début de championnat et on vous reçoit
un grand plaisir tout au long de la
saison et après le football américain
nous avons avec soccer ne tienne les
filles de 12 et féminines de mon team
retenus recevront ce dimanche à 17h30
val d'europe à l'occasion de la 8e
journée de dh les i montagne doivent
rebondir après leur défaite 2 0 contre
calais au premier tour fédéral de la
coupe
france la victoire est donc impérative
pour la confiance mais également pour le
classement montigny sixième est talonné
par val d'europe quatre points seulement
les séparent le match s'annonce donc
passionnant florane on l'attend avec
impatience on termine cette chronique
par du rugby est un choc qu'il ne faudra
pas rater pour le sky rugby l'équipe du
coach c'est thomas payen un choc vous
allez trouver le mot juste florane le
sky rugby rosso premiers du classement
de promotion d'honneur reçoit ce
dimanche à 14h30 le troisième du
championnat terre de france en cas de
victoire le sky terminera l'année 2015
en tête la montée deviendra alors de
plus en plus concrète pour les yvelinois
sur la pelouse du stade des boues
desclaux il devrait y avoir du spectacle
les saint-quentinois ont déjà marqué 148
points depuis le début de la saison à
match ne pas manquer donc floral s'ils
voulaient ma compagne et dimanche je
serai présent stade a désolé mais quelle
je me suis programme une petite séance
de renesmée une prochaine fois peut-être
certainement ses notes et langil bonne
mémoire merci à vous et à lundi pour
cette histoire ce sera le dernier de
notre année 2015 qu'est ce que l'art est
debout alors je vous prépare un petit
paris nice du cyclisme avec paris nice
mais également du golfe avec le portrait
de la future pépite du golf français
benjamin jahier un sportif originaire de
montigny-le-bretonneux dernier cette
fuite sport de l'année 2015 il ne faudra
pas le rater c'est la fin de cette
édition merci nous avoir suivis de moins
vous avez rendez vous avec wilfrid
errishi pour l'édition du journal de
vendredi avec l'essentiel de l'actualité
quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi pour
le journal je vous souhaite donc une
bonne soirée peut être déjà des bonnes
vacances au revoir